we begin in South Africa where Al
jazeera's investigative unit has
uncovered a large-scale money laundering
operation the scheme implicates some of
the country's biggest banks a former
member of the criminal Syndicate has
spoken exclusively to Al Jazeera
Alexander James has this report
Khan is a former money launderer he
fears for his life and is speaking
exclusively to Al jazeera's
investigative unit from a safe house he
says his role was to forge paperwork to
disguise the money laundering as
legitimate transactions in the office we
had a strong one
and in the strong room we had boxes upon
boxes of Bank stamps we had boxes of
passports with boxes of ID documents
head of the operation is dowd's brother
Muhammad Khan his street name is Mo
dollars his financial services firm
served as a front for the laundering he
sort of held up as this sort of shadowy
figure that controls money laundering in
South Africa that everybody wants to
find wants to locate wants to discuss
wants to catch wants to prosecute or
wants to use
we've obtained a trove of thousands of
documents that reveal fake invoices from
fictitious suppliers addressed to Mo
dollars clients no Goods no Services
purely just money bonding
and I can tell you that with 100
certainty because
I done that logo
we conceal the identity of one of Mo
Dollar's former business partners
Muhammad Khan is known for Money Lottery
a million in profit today
transferring to different countries to
different places
and you got other connections to do that
to ensure the scheme success the
launderers bribe employees at South
Africa's Banks you look after us you
push through all our payments no
questions asked on the specific company
and will match your salary
every month in cash
a ledger records Kickbacks paid to staff
at SAS Finn Bank who are responsible for
processing foreign payments we were
actually the executive management team
of the cesvin Forex processing
Department if I can put it to you that
way Muhammad was CEO of of that company
without them knowing
The Ledger records bribes paid to
employees at other Banks too
he is a senior manager at the compliance
division of Standard Bank South Africa
and also is the key complicated to the
South African Reserve Bank I can make a
phone call for you now to individuals in
Absa Bank
that would put whatever you tell them to
put on a letterhead for you and they
would stamp it
Muhammad Khan told us that all the
allegations against him were false and
based on manufactured evidence he denied
bribing anyone in the South African
banking sector Vivian Nike denied
involvement in a money laundering
syndicas sasfin said it was taking
vigorous action against former employees
Absa passed on our findings to its
forensic investigative unit and Standard
Bank told us it takes a zero tolerance
approach to fraud and criminality
Alexander James Al Jazeera
well Karam saying is the executive
director of corruption watch he says the
revelations are not entirely surprising
it's important to know that you know
South Africa has gone through a very
difficult period in terms of uh what we
characterized as state capture whereby
uh whether it be at the high echelons of
the police service or within our
Prosecuting Services we sold the
hollowing out of law enforcement
institutions and institutions that that
promote accountability so it's fair to
say you know across the board that South
Africa's enforcement of things like
money laundering and and the fight
against organized crime and Corruption
has been really challenged and weakened
in this period uh and it's recognized
and acknowledged broadly that these are
areas that uh that we need to see
massive Improvement if we want to turn a
corner around uh um you know the grips
uh that the economy finds itself when it
comes to organized crime
you know that the the announcement of
the financial action task force to grade
list South Africa was a an announcement
that came out last month
um you know it it's it's quite
significant uh for the country it
basically says it you know South Africa
you know cannot be vouched for as a as a
safe investment a destination given the
types of weaknesses that that we're
talking about in terms of the anti-money
laundering a framework so um you know
this great listing really puts the South
African government on terms in terms of
ensuring that uh you know significant
progress is made both in terms of uh
legal reforms required but then also in
terms of implementing those and and in
terms of enforcement and you can watch
the next installment of our four-part
series gold Mafia smoke and mirrors the
full episode is coming up on altazira at
20 GMT